happy fourth of july everybody it's the
mariners and the rangers the finale
of this series the rubber match good
pitching match up with chris flexon
taking on mike poulton
we are ready for action
swinging a and that's a good start to
get eli white who had a three run homer
last night one-two pitch
struck him out flexing great start
couple of k's the eighth going an
explosive start on the fourth of july
how about the season numbers for folky
16 starts here a just over five
62 strikeouts for him so far this season
that is in 87 innings payoff from fulton
in the air
out to right field and that'll be a
routine play for joey gallo
eventually yeah there it is
this fastball lifted
into short left field
and coming in for it david dahl so every
outfielder got a chance and they all did
a very nice job
let's go to the second inning no score
three or two to gallow
swaying a miss struck him out let's
run up three strikeouts among the first
four men that he's faced
with the kick save glad he got rid of it
here's demo on the move and a crossbody
throw well done one two three in the
second
first inning he went after him with his
fastball top of the zone
last thing we saw the change up
dribbler type france you get it
speaking of a changeup
he does he does put his name on it easy
play out there for bauer two down
easy play for demo
little more throws him out and chris
flexing nine up nine down rolling early
very dissatisfied with that breaking
ball
he'll love that one right on the inside
corner back-to-back strikeouts for
fulton
faulty's 2-2 to shed long
oh strike three called as he gets that
inside top corner of the zone three
straight strikeouts all looking
make sure your your fingers are dry
crawford oh does not like that pop-up
[Applause]
inning over a one two three jp crawford
is angry at that back 205 era at home
that's hanging up who can get under it
it's going to be power
powers makes the catch
flagship radio station talking about he
got with his trainer
there's the first base hit
of the ball game for the rangers
[Applause]
both these guys have good speed here
comes shed he's there
flexing gives up a harlot harmless
single as we go bottom four no score so
two on and two away and that'll bring up
catcher luis terence
he goes that way drives gallow back
going back on back on
luis terrence
a power surge this week a three-run jack
mariners in front here on texas on the
fourth of july the first explosion of
the day
for luis his ninth home run takes his
rbi total
to 19 a little rocket red glare
well for luis he figured it out first
three pitches away from him set up away
again and he looks out over the plate
this is belt eye and drives it over the
fence in right field
big flex goes two or two here against
time
easy fly ball
center fielder kevin on it's going to be
frailing
wow
i might not have seen it exactly right
off the bat no he didn't he kind of
froze a little bit in center field by
the time he picked it up i think the
infielders were assuming he had it all
the way he is calling it towards the end
come back now
locked it like a goalie throws high but
in time
well done
through five flex mariners they lead it
three nothing
here is left fielder shed long he leans
on this one
way back way back and gone
shed long with the family in the
building gives the mariners a four
nothing lead his fourth home run of the
season is 14th rbi oh did he get into
that one
fam is here
they have a turn for this it's called
back legging him and that's exactly what
happens right here he stays on the back
side leans back
keeps it fair and hits it off the
restaurant
exit velo of 110 423 feet that is
crushed great numbers for the mariners
when they get four or more runs
and luis holds on
strikeout number four first since the
second inning one down in here in the
sixth
two outs two on mariners lead at four
nothing in the sixth inning
when he taps it by the mound flexon
tumbles after it but will have no play
now the rangers get on the board
garcia with an infield hit drives in
white and it will get the time run to
the plate that's not what we had in mind
in terms of a big at bat but it'll work
payoff pitch runner's going to take off
a 3-2 to gallow
swaying in a mistrucky man
keeps the lead at 4-1 a big k ring up by
chris flexon 4-1 mariners round number
one that brings up avanya the 2-0
swinging it's popped up second rider
points to the sky here comes dylan moore
he's calling everybody off and he makes
the catches ty france stands right next
to him like a statue looking up into the
sun
here's david dahl here's the pitch
swinging it's a high fly ball out to
left field shed long
has got a beat on it and he makes the
catch lead off walk first walk today
from fulton evac here comes jake bowers
three spots
near the foul line behind third and kind
of philippe takes care of it so one away
here in the home half of the seventh
dylan moore
that's a big swing by
moore but not going to leave the yard
doll able to get back to it
[Applause]
this one lined to second base i guess it
hopped
throws out shed long junior and the
inning is done holt is in at second base
with a one-out double and that'll bring
up lead on banners center fielder eli
white swinging a mascot
one aboard for texas and the battle will
be first baseman nate lowe the mariners
stand in the yard easy play who's to get
it it will be shed long having a good
day out in the
left field and at the plate now the
rangers are down to their final out of
the ball game and here comes fraley's
that hang and it's hanging he's got it
and that ladies and gentlemen is your
ball game mariners win it by the count
of four to one take this series two
games to one they're now six and one
at home against the rangers and seven
and three on the season what a good win